[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIANNE SLIGHT:
What we want to talk
to you about this afternoon is
the truth about health data.
So many of you, I'm sure, are
working with life science data
or with health care data.
And for some of those
sources, it's quite OK.
So EHR data now, generally,
is coming to us in a--
well, it's not quite a modern
format, is it, HL7, Version 2?
But we've got FHIR,
we've got HL7 Version 3.
We have-- somebody
told me yesterday
it's now 40 years old, the
X12 claims format standard.
And that's OK.
We know how to deal with that.
We now, in Google Cloud,
have a health care API
that's in beta that can bring
in data in HL7 Version 2
and FHIR in its native formats.
Medical imaging data typically
comes in in DICOM format.
Or pathology systems often have
a slightly different format
as well.
But again, we recognize those,
we know those pretty well,
and we also have DICOM
support within our health API.
Genomic data-- in health
care and life sciences,
we think about bringing all of
these different types of data,
different modalities
of data, together.
And typically, we look
for different variants.
And so we bring in those
variant data in VCF files
directly into BigQuery.
And that all works too.
We have an API for that.
That's fantastic.
We've got a couple of
emerging types of data
that we're seeing more
and more commonly.
And I know you guys are
starting to think about how
you're going to use that data.
You know you want
to use that data.
But the challenge with
that is that there's
no common standards yet
for that kind of data.
And so that's something
that we're watching.
The space will work to
do these kinds of tools
that we need to
ingest it over time.
The one that's missing
here is that text data,
that unstructured
clinical notes, the notes
that physicians write
as they're documenting
either your progress within an
acute stay, or discharge notes,
and so on.
And we see that come through
in lots of different formats.
Sometimes we see it
coming through the wire
on top of a PDF interface.
And then we need
to think about how
you're going to OCR that, how
you're going to understand
what's really in that content.
So the way that I like to think
about these different data sets
is from top to bottom.
These are small to large
types of data sets.
Genomics is absolutely enormous,
somewhere in the middle.
But in terms of
messiness, I think
EHR data, and particularly
clinical notes data,
is some of the messiest.
It's some of the hardest
to extract real value
from when you're trying to
integrate multiple sources
of that together.
So let's talk a little bit
about those clinical notes.
Here's a sample of a note from
a patient who was in the ICU.
Notes are dense, right?
There's a lot of data
up there in that note.
And in addition, there are
many, many abbreviations.
And actually, often,
some of the abbreviations
are in Latin as well.
And so it's not really
obvious around how
you go about extracting
the clinical meaning.
And yet there's clearly a lot of
clinical meaning in this note.
In addition, because
of the lovely vagaries
of our different EMR systems,
never mind the unwillingness
of our physicians to
learn to type well,
we have all sorts of
punctuation issues.
There are spaces
that are missing.
There are, in some cases,
very structured approaches
to using a semicolon
versus a comma.
But each one is
different, and each note
from each different
institution often
has a very different format.
They're long.
This is an ICU note.
No, I think this is
a neurology note.
They're very long in many cases.
And so that's a lot of
information to plow through.
Sometimes they're
not unstructured.
They contain structure.
They contain tabular data.
And that can be hard for an
NLP system, a Natural Language
Processing system, to really
understand, especially
when the raw data for this
table didn't look like this.
What it looked like was more of
a bespoke structure like that.
And what's interesting
about this--
so it's probably a bit hard
to see from down there,
but this is some lab data,
and the names of the labs,
I actually highlighted
in red here.
The challenge with
this is that you'll
notice that there
are lots of gaps
in the table because
the data wasn't
fully dense for every
single time period.
There wasn't a lab at
every single time period.
And so sometimes you
have to interpolate
on which piece of data
belongs to which time period.
That sort of semi-structured
data can be really difficult.
And when we think about
semi-structured data,
it's not just tabular data
like this and other labs.
It also includes things
like understanding
notes sections,
where you might have,
for example, in a SOAP note--
a Subjective, Objective,
Assessment, and a Plan--
You might have different
types of note headers
that give you some
metadata about that note.
But that, too, needs its
own special kind of parsing.
Or you might also have
many different notes.
You often have many
different notes
for a particular encounter.
And the most common example
of this is within the ICU,
where patients
stay for typically
a longer period of time.
The other challenge
that's increased
as we think about
electronic medical records
is that notes are
often copied forward.
And this has definitely
been exacerbated
with the increase in
EMR usage, not least
because the meaningful
use regulations that
were so compelling in
terms of EMR adoption--
because they initially waived
the carrot of some money,
and then waved a stick
of taking money away--
forced the adoption
of an EMR system.
But that EMR system
needed to be updated
with different regulatory
content every two years.
And so the EMR vendors
really struggled to keep up.
And so what went by the
wayside was usability.
And so physicians got
fed up, got burned out.
And the EMR was introduced
ways to accelerate,
for them, the entry of
that clinical findings,
the entry of those
clinical notes.
And one of the ways
they did that was
with copy forward or
copy and paste, from one
note to another.
This is from a
paper two years ago.
And the paper was
done based on data
at University of California
San Francisco Medical Center.
It used Epic, but we
see the same problems
in every single EMR.
I don't want to
pick on Epic here.
In a typical note--
oh, and I'm sorry, there's
a weird space there.
That should be a comma.
We analyzed 23,630 notes written
by almost 500 clinicians,
and found that, in a typical
note, almost 50% of that note
was copied.
Another 36% was imported,
and only 18% of the text
was manually entered.
That's a huge
amount, particularly
of the copied, copied forward,
copied from other places.
And the graph here shows the
prevalence of progress notes
by the amount of
manually-entered text.
So relatively little
fully manually-entered
text, a huge amount, with very
little manually-entered text.
So this is a problem.
It's a problem to
try and understand,
to pull out, the richness
of the information
that's buried in
that clinical note.
Because the clinical
note is supposed
to be the repository of the
physician's thinking process,
decision-making
process, the evidence
that they found, how they did
the differential diagnosis,
and what the treatment
plan is for the patient.
And that decision-making
process isn't really
captured anywhere else.
So it's really important
to be able to mine
the wealth of this
information that's
buried in the data
of the clinical note.
So what are we doing about it?
And when you think about
ingesting health care and life
science data, how do you think
about getting the information
out of that data, aligned into
a single environment for you
to use as the basis of
analysis for machine learning?
Well, when we think about it,
after that ingestion piece,
where will you bring your
data onto Google Cloud,
the next thing
that we think about
is how you harmonize the data
from those different sources
that you have so that it all
speaks the same language.
And the way that
we think about that
is from a historical data
perspective, and then
incremental and
streaming perspectives.
Because when you think about
bringing data onto cloud,
usually you're starting with
something that exists already,
whether that's a
pile of CSV files,
whether that's an archival
database that you already have,
whether it's an existing CDW
or an existing data lake,
or maybe an existing
Clarity database, et cetera.
And so bringing that
historical data in
is very similar, in
a way, to bringing
in the incremental
or the streaming data
from the harmonization
perspective.
Not from the
ingestion perspective,
but from the
harmonization perspective.
It's just there are some
different formats as well.
And I'm focusing, in
this picture here,
on data from electronic
health records.
But equally, this could include
DICOM data from imaging,
and it could include VCF file
data, as well, from genomics.
From an incremental data
perspective, as well as
those snapshot increments of
CSV, or pulling it directly
from another database,
more commonly,
with health care data,
that incremental data
is HL7 messages, or
FHIR messages as well.
And the transformations
that we need to do
are really in these four forms.
The first is field mappings.
So you've got maybe five
hospitals, let's say--
maybe 105 hospitals,
on one side.
And not every single one of
them are using a different EMR.
But I'll bet you many of them
are using a different EMR
instance, which is configured
differently from the next EMR
instance, and often they
are using different EMRs.
Even in very large
health systems--
I've been talking
to one recently
that has more than 50 hospitals.
They still have Epic, they have
Meditech, they have Allscripts.
And those Epic instances--
there's a lot of them--
they're all
differently configured.
So as you bring
in that data, what
that means is that
you've got lots
of different schemas of
source coming into the system.
And so how do you want
to align that data?
Do you want to align it to FHIR?
Do you have a schema
in mind already
that you want to align it to?
Is it one of the
standard schemas?
Unfortunately, there's a
plethora of common data models,
such as OMOP, which
is commonly used
within research organizations
and within pharma
companies, CDISC, which
you need from a pharma
perspective for things like us
STDM, i2b2, or your own custom
schema.
So what we're trying to do, from
a harmonization perspective,
is understand these
target schemas
as first-class health care
data citizens in the same way
that we understand FHIR,
and HL7, and DICOM, and VCF
as first-class data
transmission citizens.
And if you don't want to use
one of these first-class data
citizens, you don't have to.
If you've got a schema that
you're particularly keen on,
that works, too.
But what's important
is aligning the data
from all your different sources
into that single target.
And how you do that is
really with these four types
of transformation.
So first of all,
the field mappings.
When I say Pat ID
up here, and then I
say PT underscore ID here,
and then I say MRN over there,
I need to know that that
goes to Patient underscore
ID over here.
That's very simplistic.
The second area is around
terminology mappings.
Because often, those
same multiplicity
of different sources also
use different terminologies
for the same concept.
For example, this hospital uses
RxNorm as its primary dimension
table for medications, but
this hospital over there
uses FDB, and that
one uses [? Multim. ?]
And so that's just an example
on the medication side.
When you think about extensions
that groups have made--
whether that's
regional extensions,
whether that's versions
of terminologies
that people are using
for different purposes--
all of those
terminology mappings
need to happen as well.
And so far, we're just talking
about the structured data
for data harmonization,
but I'm going
to come to the unstructured
text in a moment.
The third area of mapping
transformation is units.
Because when you're
in a NICU, and you're
measuring the weight,
the mass of a neonate,
typically, that's done in grams.
But when you're measuring the
weight of an adult in a CV ICU,
for example, that's typically
done in pounds or kilos.
And so making sure that
that units alignment happens
is really critical to being able
to use the data for analytics
or machine learning.
And it's not just weight, it's
also all those labs as well.
And then the fourth
type, which is the type
that I'm going to spend the
rest of this talk focusing on,
is clinical entity extraction.
Understanding, extracting
out, those clinical concepts
and the items within
their own ontologies
into structured data, and
augmenting the structured data
with those items.
But there are
different approaches
for different use cases.
And this is where NLP becomes
really, really interesting,
I think.
So from a physician's
perspective,
what they want to do
is have a system that
plows through their
clinical notes
and extracts out all of
those clinical entities
that they were just busy
dictating or busy typing
into their clinical note, and
have those added into the EMR
as structured data,
or at least have them
added into the clinical
warehouse for analytics.
But the rules that they use
for determining what to extract
and how to code those
is very different--
it really is-- from the
rules that a medical coder
must follow in order for the
hospital to be reimbursed
or for the physician
to be reimbursed.
So if you look at
the coder training,
they don't go through x many
years of medical school.
Instead, they go through x
many years or months of AHIMA
training, and then
they're delivered
with a book that's about
that thick that's the coding
guidelines, updated every
year, that lands on their desk.
And those rules are different
from what a physician thinks
about in terms of the way
that different diagnoses are
defined, for example.
So sepsis means one
thing to a physician,
and it means something entirely
different to a medical coder--
not entirely different,
but different enough.
Those are different rules
that they must follow.
From a CDI perspective,
a Clinical Documentation
Improvement specialist,
their job is to,
from an inpatient perspective,
go through the documentation
and look for opportunities where
there is clinical evidence that
suggests a different diagnosis.
So that's another use case
for this clinical entity
extraction.
And from the
payer's perspective,
they want to look at
the clinical notes
in order to identify any
fraud, waste, or abuse.
And so again, that's a
different perspective.
And as any of you who've been
using machine learning know,
there's a large
difference between models
that you create for compliance
versus for discovery.
So one size does not
fit all in this case,
and one NLP model does not fit
all, either, because of this.
So maybe-- there we go.
I'm sorry if I was
blinding somebody.
Let's talk, then, about our
approach to natural language
processing.
And I want to say this
is a preview of what
we're building here at Google.
But we're going to
follow these five steps.
So in order to extract
that clinical information
for a patient,
we're starting off
with named entity recognition.
And named entity
recognition means
scanning all of
that text, finding
all of those clinical entities,
finding all of the concepts.
And this is a task that is very
suitable for machine learning.
All it requires is
lots and lots of data,
and data that is labeled--
lots of labeling as well--
to identify not just
the clinical concepts
themselves, but also
where it found them
in the document, the
positional information.
That needs a lot of
data because we have
a lot of medical specialties.
We have a huge amount
now of ICD-10 codes,
including procedure codes,
and a huge amount of things
like LOINC codes as well, which
leads me on to my second piece.
Ooh, where did that go?
Ooh, come back.
There we go.
Sorry.
Oh, let's go back one.
My builds didn't work, did they?
The second piece is mapping
those named entity recognitions
into the ontology, and then
into the item classification
for each of those
medical concepts.
So you need to decide, when
you're doing natural language
processing and you're
extracting out medications,
what do you want to map to?
Do you want to map
to FDB because that's
what you use within
your health system?
Do you want to map to RxNorm
because that's typically
what everybody else is
using around for analytics?
Or do you want to use
[? Multim ?] because maybe
you've got some medication
interaction tracking system
that's based on [? Multim? ?]
So you need to
understand, once you've
identified which
ontology you want to use,
which concept each
entity belongs to.
And this is sometimes more
complicated than it sounds,
and I'll give you an example.
So when you say something
like penicillin,
that could mean a
medication order,
or it could mean a
medication allergy.
And so you need to
start understanding
the difference between those,
and choosing the right concept
that the entity belongs to, and
then choosing the right item
within that concept list.
Again, extensive training data,
but fundamentally a machine
language problem.
OK, now let's try
for number 3, maybe.
OK, number 3 is
the semantic model.
It's all very well to be able
to extract out those entities,
map them to what the ontology
is and the terminology you
want to use.
But that's not enough.
Because what about when
the physician says,
rule out chest pneumonia,
rule out something else,
some other diagnosis?
Patient does not have
blah-dy-blah, so negation.
You need to start thinking
about a semantic model that
handles that negation,
that handles what I always
like to say, the fear,
uncertainty, and doubt.
"Could be" doesn't mean
the patient has it.
Doing a differential
diagnosis, understanding
the typical language that's used
for a differential diagnosis,
understanding the
difference between time--
between patient had
pneumonia three months ago,
but that's since been resolved--
versus this patient has
pneumonia.
Understanding who
has the entity.
Patient's mother died
of a heart attack.
That heart attack
doesn't accrue.
It doesn't get assigned
to the patient.
It gets assigned as a
part of a family history.
And that's the simple
types of semantic model.
There are other, more
complicated types.
Things like chest pain, in the
presence of something else,
might lead you to a
different diagnosis.
And so those are
two different areas
that need to be handled within
natural language processing
and clinical entity extraction.
I see it's done it again.
Ah, I apologize.
Number 4 is the
context of the patient.
One note doesn't give you all
the history of the patient,
does it?
And sometimes you
need more information
from the rest of
the note in order
to understand what to extract.
And this is particularly common
within the medical coding
example.
In medical coding, you want
all of the notes associated
for that patient from
this particular encounter,
and yet not all of the notes.
What you want to do--
ah, come back.
I do apologize.
There we go.
You also need to take in
the context of the use case.
Because for medical coding,
it's not all note types,
it's only certain note
types for this encounter.
And so you need to really grok
the context of that broader use
case, understand what
the guidelines are,
and then make sure that
that is appropriate,
that you're building a flow
that is appropriate for that.
And so any additional ontologies
that you need to layer in,
any sections of notes,
parsing the notes to make
the different sections,
and then doing,
of course, all the wiring up
of getting the notes there
in the first place.
So when we think about
natural language processing
and clinical entity
extraction, these
are the five areas
that we're looking at.
And what we're
working on right now
is the ability to
provide an API that
would allow you to do the
first portions of this.
To us, named entity
recognition is insufficient.
That doesn't help you
dramatically on its own.
What you need to do is include
the concept classification
and the semantic model in
order to have clinical entity
extraction.
And so now what I'd like
to do is talk a little bit
about a couple of other
items, and then we're
going to move to a demo.
So the first piece
is around tuning,
because every health system has
different unique documentation
practices.
And so in some cases, they'll
all go with a SOAP note.
That's not very common
that they'll all
go with a SOAP note.
But in other places, they'll
have a particular structure
that they want to use.
And often, that
differs by specialty.
And also, often,
things like how they
use abbreviations
is very different,
and is driven by
the health system
as some kind of
overall guideline.
There is often a
unique use of terms.
I remember working
with a system that
often used the abbreviation
OB, which one NLP system took
to mean obstetrics.
And actually, they
meant obesity.
The patient had obesity.
And that, we only discovered
when we started looking really
at the data quality issues.
There are often
unique guidelines
because, for example, some
organizations will take
a different approach to risk.
And so that will tweak
the model, particularly,
when you're looking at things
from a compliance perspective.
So let's take a
look at the demo.
Just before we
switch there, I want
to give you a brief
introduction to the demo
that we're going to show.
So this is a preview.
This isn't available today.
And what we're
going to show you is
how you will be able to
integrate any existing NLP
solution you have
with Google Cloud,
and extend it by leveraging
Google Cloud's capabilities as
well.
And so, fundamentally,
what we're going to do
is show you a Jupyter
Notebook, which
is a collaborative
analytics notebook.
It's connected to BigQuery.
And we're going to show
you two different NLP
models and how they can
be integrated together.
One NLP model that
we're going to show
is one that many
of you, I'm sure,
are familiar with,
which is cTAKES.
It's an open-source NLP model.
The other is one of our Google
research models for NLP.
It's a research model
that is clinically based.
And the reason that I've got
all of these items differently
colored is because
you're going to start
to see different
concepts extracted
by the different models.
So for example, in
the cTAKES model,
we are using coding
for that to SNOMED
and medications to RxNorm.
But the research model
that we're going to use
goes a lot deeper on
the medication side,
and it also identifies
different types of PHI.
So I won't remember
these colors.
You don't have to remember
the colors either.
But we'll point out
some of the differences.
So if we could switch
to the demo, please.
Great.
So the first steps in here--
so this is a Jupyter Notebook.
The first steps that
we're going to do
are just to import all of
the libraries in Python,
and start loading up
all of the gubbins
that we need in order
to run NLP here.
And that's done.
And now we're going to--
I'm reading from
the screen here--
load up the notes and the
annotations from BigQuery.
Because in this case,
we're using this directly
on top of BigQuery.
And the data that we're
using here to train the model
was from i2b2, which
you can see in there.
But the nodes that
we're testing this with
are new notes that the model
hasn't seen previously.
And so you can see
here, we've loaded up
a whole bunch of notes, and
now what we're going to do
is visualize the annotations.
You can see we've
loaded up 396 notes,
I think, or concepts there.
So let's scroll down a bit
so that we can see this.
So we've got three
different notes
that we're going
to show you here.
The first is a discharge note.
It's quite common
for a discharge note
to be this sort
of length, but you
can see there's lots of
different areas within that.
Now, we're going to
have to scroll up
to see what the different models
are finding from this note.
So the first one that we're
going to look at is cTAKES.
And I'll remind
you of the colors
because that one's easy for
me to remember for cTAKES.
So the red things here
are coded to SNOMED,
and the green things
here are coded to RxNorm.
And the pure green thing, that
Tamiflu, is a real RxNorm.
The other paler
green things means
that it could be coded to
either SNOMED or RxNorm.
So in a system that you're
building, you need to decide.
You need to decide which one it
would be for each one of those.
OK, it's found a
whole bunch of things,
but it's missed a whole
bunch of things too.
It's missed all
of the information
about the medications.
It found the medication
name, but it missed all
of the information about them.
So now let's switch to the
research model, which we know--
just because I gave you the
prompt earlier with the color
coding--
we know that that's going to
find a lot more medications.
And it has.
So what it's found
is blue is showing
the different medications.
Green is showing information
about the dosage.
The reddish color is showing
different information
about the roots,
I think, and you
can see that there is a lot
of different information.
A Mrs. Smith has been
identified, because that's PHI,
and we know that
this research model
is geared towards
PHI and medication
depth of information.
So it's found a lot
of different things,
but it's not found everything
that cTAKES found because it's
not geared towards finding
all of the conditions, all
the procedures, all
the typical things
that cTAKES is geared towards.
So what we've been able to do
is to merge those two together.
And we haven't merged the
model, but we're integrating
the results of the two models.
And that, Donny's now displaying
through this Both tab,
this Final tab up here.
And so it's showing all of
the different information that
was found.
And if you hover
over any item, it'll
tell you how it was coded.
And so this starts
to show you the power
of the kinds of things
that we're building here
for clinical entity extraction.
That's great.
Let's try it on another note.
Let's try it on--
actually, can we try it
on the admissions note?
So this is a completely
different type of note.
An admissions note is giving
you a lot more information
about the diagnostics,
from admitting,
past medical history, and so on.
And so after the
past medical history,
we've got a bunch of
medication at home, allergies.
We've got a physical exam.
We've got the social
history, and then
the assessment and plan.
OK, let's go run this
through our different models
and see what we find.
So from a cTAKES
perspective, again, we're
finding a lot of the diagnoses
or a lot of the conditions--
things like nausea, vomiting,
headache, patient's confused,
patient has chronic cough.
She did attempt to eat a
banana with a peel still on.
Interesting.
She is quite independent.
She has a history
of bipolar disorder.
And if we scroll down to
the medications, please,
Donny, we should be able
to see further down--
there we go.
We can start to see
some of the medications
that this poor
patient is on as well.
But it hasn't found all
of them, and it certainly
hasn't identified,
again, the dosage,
the root of the medication, and
whether it's active, and so on.
So now, let's apply
our research model.
This is the same research
model that we've applied
in the previous example.
And actually, it's
quite light at the top.
If you scroll back
up a little bit,
it's quite light at the top.
Because this one
isn't trying to find
all of those different
conditions and procedures.
It's focused on PHI, and
it's focused on medications.
So as we would expect,
most of the highlights
up there are around PHI.
There's some purple
up there too,
which relates to the
time organization.
Remember that I talked
before about needing
to understand tents,
whether it's historic
or what period of time
something applies to.
But as we scroll down
to the medications,
it's a bit like a rainbow.
We found all of that
different information
about the different medications
that this patient is on.
And so that's really valuable.
Now, if we merge
the two together,
then it allows us to
see that combination,
and truly do that extraction
of clinical entities
that is a union of these
different items with any coding
from the first one
going to SNOMED,
any coding from the second
model going to RxNorm,
and all of that being
integrated together.
So why do I show you this?
Because this shows
you a pathway for how
you can do clinical entity
extraction on Google Cloud,
even as we're still
bringing on, testing,
building our NLP models to
understand clinical language.
We have a great Natural
Language API out there,
but it's not clinically
focused, and so
this starts to give you
the idea that as we build
our clinical NLP API,
you can use it and also
augment it with other types
of models that you are doing.
So let's take a look now
at the different types
of clinical concept that
we found within a data set.
And so Donny's running some
more Python code for me.
Thank you.
And if we scroll down, then we
can see the different concepts
that each of the different
models has found.
So actually, let's look
at cTAKES first, please.
Thank you.
So cTAKES, if you
look at those items
that it's found the most stuff
within this documentation
training set, as you
would expect, most of them
are related to
diagnoses or procedures,
related to parts of the body.
Because that's what
cTAKES is so good at.
Some of them are
medications, but most of them
relate to conditions
and procedures.
Whereas if we look at
the research model, most
of these items-- well, you
won't find specific PHI items
because, obviously,
you only find a few
of those within each note.
So unless we have all of our
patients named Mrs. Smith,
you're not going to see a
large amount of PHI up there,
but you do see a lot of
different medications.
Donny, if you scroll
down a bit more, please,
this is a word cloud of what
the two different models found.
So again, on the
cTAKES model, lots
of different complaints,
different procedures, different
diagnoses.
Definitely some
medications, as well,
because cTAKES does find
some aspects of medications.
But compare that with
the research one,
and I love this research one.
Pain.
Pain is the biggest
item it finds.
But you can see here, lots
of different medications--
heparin, Percocet, Colace,
aspirin, tablet, Coumadin.
This one is much
more focused, as you
know, towards finding
the medications,
but then also
finding the amounts
of the different
medications and the roots
medications, and the reasons
for why they were prescribed.
Finally, the last
thing that we're
going to do as part
of this demo is
find all of the notes that
make a positive mention
of a particular drug--
in our case, vancomycin.
And it found 44 of those.
And the way it was
doing that is using,
I think, the cTAKES model.
And so this also gives you a way
to start to look at your data
and start to do some data
quality on it as well.
OK, so if we could flip
back, please, to the slides.
And I'll see if I can
actually use this beastie.
So the important thing to take
away from this presentation
is that you don't need
to do everything at once.
We'll meet you where
you are, and that's true
bringing structured
data, bringing data
across different modalities into
Google Cloud for health care
data, as well as for
clinical entity extraction.
We offer a framework
in which to do
this, in which to do the data
ingestion with health care,
understanding data
formats ingestion parts
within our cloud health
care API, understanding HR7,
understanding FHIR
understanding DICOM.
We are building a framework
for cloud CDW where, again, you
can use our data
harmonization tools.
If you have data harmonization
tools that you already
have built, you can use those.
You can migrate
slowly over time.
You can do what
you like with that
in regards to your own tools or
other APIs that you've licensed
versus using ours.
And the same is true for
clinical entity extraction
for natural language processing.
You can bring your own model.
You can use one of ours as we
develop them and release them.
Or you can use a
partner's model.
So one of the things
that we're looking
to extend cloud
marketplace to is
to enable the availability
of partners' clinical entity
extraction models,
as well, on there.
And so don't wait.
This was a preview, but if
you're using somebody's NLP
models and you want to get
started with that on cloud,
you can do that.
And over time, you can tell
from this presentation,
we're doing a lot of investment
in this area right now.
And so you can look to
see our NLP models become
refined and more specific
around clinical data as well.
So with that, thank
you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]